Remix video is about re mixing the stories that make up our world,
right?
Where were we?
We,
well,
we,
we live off of stories.
We understand the world based on stories,
based on narratives.
We understand our place in it and the commute,
the connections between things based on stories.
You know,
people more and more are taking those stories and saying,
this is a story that was given to me,
you know,
on the TV or in the movies or on the radio and it's not quite what I want,
what I want.
It doesn't,
it doesn't work for me.
So I'm going to change that story a little bit.
Uh,
I'm going to add something too.
I'm going to take something away from it.
Um,
and I'll create a new narrative based on what I'm missing in the well.
And I actually think that that,
uh,
that kind of thing,
um,
has mass appeal.
I mean,
people who know the original source then are really interested in this
alternative version of,
of,
of that source.
For me,
remix video,
um,
is much more accessible,
and much more populist and much more participatory.
Then video art has been traditionally.
And,
and in that way,
I think it's much more important,
much more relevant and says much,
much,
much more because really what is art?
But it could be communication tool,
you know,
if,
if you're,
if you've got video artists who were intending their work to be seen by other
artists,
um,
by gallery,
the,
uh,
owners or by people who are interested in high art or academic art or art theory
and methods,
a very small sort of elite group of people,
um,
who might sit through a long kind of boring,
strange experimental video piece.
Whereas the political remixers,
uh,
or the,
the remix video artists for the most part on,
you know,
on,
on most of their work is what is on the Internet right now.
Um,
but even before the Internet,
this work was meant for a general audience for and for,
for me,
the question of,
you know,
is the world functioning on,
in,
uh,
in a remix way,
um,
is a given?
Yes,
of course.
You know,
I,
I think it has been for a long time.
I mean,
you can look at Star Wars and say,
you know,
Star Wars is almost taking shot for shot from a Japanese films,
of a decade or two decades earlier.
Um,
you know,
and,
and uh,
so for me that's just a given.
That's just,
yes,
of course.
Um,
and what the question for me that I think is most interesting,
the question for me is,
um,
remix is a,
is a tool.
It's a medium.
And the question is,
what do you do with that medium?
What are you trying to say?
Are you challenging traditional power structures?
Are you challenging a stereotypical notions about gender or sexuality or class
or race?
You know,
are you challenging,
um,
government or corporate institutions,
uh,
through your remix work in some way?
It could be funny,
it could be interesting,
it could be entertaining,
but you know,
what does that sort of subversive messages,
you know,
what are the ethics of Remix?
Um,
because you're appropriating someone else's media,
right?
You're appropriating some other story that made,
was made by someone else or a group of people or a corporation or whatever.
Um,
and,
and the way that I think about it,
uh,
when I think about this question,
I think about what is it that I'm remixing,
right?
Where did it come from?
Um,
is it something that,
um,
came from a corporation or a government,
a powerful institution or not?
You know,
is it,
is it is,
where am I on the,
in the system of power,
right?
And then where is the thing I'm remixing?
Is it above me?
Is it below me?
I,
I think that you have to be very aware of the power relations of what you're
remixing.
You know?
So I encourage people to take corporate media.
I encourage people to take movies and TV shows,
um,
politicians especially and,
and,
and do what they want with it because those people are,
are,
are figures of power.
They are,
um,
and,
and they,
often,
their messages are messages of power.
Um,
but if you're looking down on,
on,
on the social sphere and you find someone who's relatively powerless and then
you remix and make fun of them,
that for me crosses the line.
Now that's my line.
The fact that Google has become that,
that Google and youtube have become so,
uh,
corporate,
um,
and,
and have built in this system,
this,
this is this automated copyright system,
um,
makes it difficult.
Often.
I mean,
I would say that maybe 10 or 15% of all the remixes that I've posted on my blog
from other people how are gone.
Many of the playlists that I have created a of my favorite remix videos they
have have,
it has holes in it,
right?
This is why I say that,
that because of the way that youtube has set up,
um,
it creates holes in the Internet,
right?
You go to a blog post and you want to see the video and it talks about the video
and you click play and it says,
I'm sorry,
blocked for content,
copyright reasons.
You know,
even when it's,
it's clearly a transformed work.
Even when it's clearly fair use,
it's,
it's gone because the robot on the other side doesn't know the difference.
You know,
there's no people looking at this and saying,
yes,
this is fair use.
Yes,
you should be able to transform the system matters.
The system that we share with manners and youtube is great because it reaches an
enormous amount of people,
you know,
way more people than you could ever hope to reach just by putting it on your own
website.
Um,
and it also has a community involved,
right?
So you meet other people who are doing things that are similar to you and you
support each other and you subscribe and you comment,
right?
All that stuff is great and important.
And it it,
for me,
I,
what I wish was that youtube was a public space.
You know,
that doesn't really exist on the Internet public space,
but I wish youtube was because it's that valuable,
right?
If it's going to be a public square,
we're going to talk about youtube and the Internet is a public square,
but it's not public.
It's private.
This is a critical moment where we have to say,
look,
this is not,
not only important and legal,
but also a critical part of communication is for the human right of
communication is to be able to use the audio visual language.
The audio visual culture to communicate with each other.
Uh,
and so in that way,
I think it's,
it's,
it's even much,
much deeper than what is traditionally thought of as art.
You know,
it's,
it's human communication.